you know those really tough calls that
producers make when it comes to
theatrical animations where they're like
alright I think it's about time we
release these on blu-ray exclusively did
yeah this is not one of those times ice
age continental drift I'm gonna call it
ice age for them all right in ice age
for we're joined by Manny the mammoth
Sid the sloth
Denis Leary the saber-tooth Tiger
because that's what I'm going to call
him and that little thing that always
tries to get that one acorn now the
continents are drifting and all the
lands moving and Manny gets separated
from his family so now he's trying to
get back to his family then he runs
across the big pirate champion well then
there's been you know we got our villain
now he's voiced by Peter Dinklage he's
in Game of Thrones and I love that dude
he's a good actor and he does have a
good voice for voice acting like I can
see him as a villain in a new Uncharted
game or something but in this movie he's
supposed to be this really ruthless
pirate ape like ian mcshane could have
voiced him and I'd be like oh that makes
sense he's really ruthless and sounds
like a pirate probably because he was a
pirate me McShane was probably like I've
been a pirate I'm not doing Ice Age so
Peter Dinklage it was so so proper you
know Lannister always pays his debts I
just kept thinking to myself like oh you
know he kind of seems like if you talked
to him you could reason with him and
he'll be like ah you know what you're
right there's no need to dick out here
go about your business sometimes I like
the character other times I was like I
like the character enough but I don't
think Peter Dinklage is the right voice
for that guy but I'm glad the guys
getting work what can I say I think that
bogged this movie down was the thing
involving Manny's daughter yeah there's
a bunch of mammoths Saved by the Bell
drama going on where she wants to be in
with the cool mammoths in school they're
like Abbi you hang out with that nerd
she's not gonna know I don't yeah by
Saved by the Bell I really mean Saved by
the Bell
I was just like can you scrap that
entire story arc and make this movie you
know an hour long some of the jokes in
this movie were kind of funny I chuckled
in a couple parts but for the most part
I was like guys just man it up and admit
like Land Before Time did you should no
longer release these theatrically and
they should go straight to DVD or
blu-ray again I understand where Fox is
coming from and they're like oh well if
we release this in 3d we're going to
make a lot more money and they will tis
the holy I can't fault them for
right but I was just watching Ice Age
for going I remember when this franchise
was starting and they really had to
compete they were like alright we're not
Shrek we're not Pixar we got to bring it
in the first
maybe they did but at this point they're
like alright the last two Pixar movies
were a subdued why do we have to try and
then I had to realize to myself I am NOT
the demographic for this movie some
animations out there go the extra mile
and they're like we need to impress the
adult as well as the kids we don't want
to bore the adults that bring the kids
to these things this is not one of those
animations you're going to take your kid
to this movie and you're gonna punch
yourself in the taint the fact that you
just spent money on tickets that you
could have saved and spent next weekend
on Dark Knight Rises tickets you know
the towel is going to go down I'm not
saying it's good or bad I'm just saying
that is fact I will say ice age
continental drift is all right you're
not gonna remember in t-minus one day
was it movie about that's how I felt
when I got out of this movie I was
driving home getting dialogue in my head
and I was like what was that movie about
you really forget a lot about it but
it's not bad enough to be kids
will have fun with it or is your
favorite Ice Age movie what is it
whatever it may be comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more